قالت معيان شيرمان والده الجندي رون
شيرمان الذي كان محتجزا في غزه ان ابنها
قتل عمدا على يد الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد ان
فضل قاده الجيش التضحيه به وفق تعبيرها
واضافت شيرمن خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه ان
التشريح الطبي لجثه ابنها يؤكد عدم وفاته
باع ناريه وانما بسبب سم القنابل التي
القيت للقضاء على قيادي في حركتها
حماس قبل يوم واحد من اخبارنا بانه مات
قالوا لنا انه على قيد الحياه بشكل شبه
مؤكد ولكن بعدها بيوم طرقوا بابنا وقالوا
لنا رون قتل على يد حماس انا شخصيا لم اكن
اريد معرفه ظروف مقتله ولكني قلت لنفسي
بانه قتل اثر اطلاق النار عليه لقد كانت
لدي افكار فضيعه عندما اخبروني بمقتله
ولهذا لم ارد ان يتم تشريحه الا بعد
اسبوعين وصلتنا رساله مفاجئه من الطبيب
الشرعي الذي عاين الجثه وعمل صورا مقطعيه
واخبرنا بعدم وجود اي جروح ناجمه عن اطلاق
نار او اي كسور او دليل على تعرضه للضرب
او علامات لكدمات او اصابه خارجيه او
صدمات